whatever
Oh I thought you were boys yeah cut okay
moving on moving on
that was a huge fan of Transformers as a
kid I was very influenced by what was
done in the past to create the
Transformers that we see today Steven's
creativity is phenomenal he's got really
inventive and fresh ideas and he's
bringing a totally different sensibility
to this movie
is about the fate of all living things
turn it up to the maximum is it the
first time the maximals are ever seen in
live action we wanted to make sure
everything was as authentic as possible
I'm not the one to fear crime
the story takes place in the 90s and so
we work really hard to capture that era
everything from the type of music we're
playing the clothes that Noah and Elena
are wearing and when it came to Casting
Anthony Ramos and Dominique Fishback
football from Brooklyn they brought
their own authentic brooklynite attitude
that just really pops on screen you
brought a human here I'm nobody I ain't
even seen nothing I'm not even seeing
anything right now
on this film we need to do something
different so we found unique locations
that showcase the size and scope of this
story We shot on top of Machu Picchu so
that was a real challenge
stepping on set with Stephen and seeing
his vision it's been amazing working
with Stephen it's all about humanity and
all about heart maybe there's a way to
save our home I've never had more fun
than I've had with Steven and Still's
confidence and he really is Sensational
let them come
pick the wheel